I fight for freedom stand with Hong Kong
and there's the hope and the expectation
that the international community will we
can't do much in this revolution but
outside what's your message to the
outside world
please save Hong Kong yes peaceful not a
riot cop in sight but not just students
either one group brandishing the Union
Jack some of the two hundred thousand to
have British national overseas passports
angry but they do not give them
permanent British residency planted in
the handover agreement twenty two years
ago even if there are still another
twenty eight years on the two systems
one country basis on which that deal was
struck with respect we very much regret
the fact the fact that the UK government
handed over Hong Kong to a fascist
country without Hong Kong people's
consent without consulting Hong Kong
people we truly regret about this so we
think that the UK has a responsibility
to - now now - to save Hong Kong people
for the coming for example a cannon -
Square 2.0 in Hong Kong do you think
that's going to happen there are more
protests this weekend police confident
that they can handle them on their own
even as fears grow of Beijing's
intentions I can tell you Tom we we are
confident that we have the capability to
maintain law and order in Hong Kong in
general from my personal contact with my
phone.i troops they are motivated we
still maintain very high morale and we
love our praise and we want to
contribute
[Music]
but the international community tends to
make precious little headway against
autocratic states and as Hong Kong's
richest man just warned the people of
his City the best cause can lead to the
worst results dynamic near Sky News Hong
Kong